passion passion passion passion past and
passion passion passion but tap dancing
to work worn how can other people tap
dance to work what's the secret of that
you find your passion you find your
passion I was very very lucky to find it
you know when I was seven or eight years
old and you know and fortunately my
children have found their passion might
you know one son loves farming like
nothing else one son loves music like
everything else and and all three of
them love philanthropy and what they get
to do you're lucky in life when you find
it and you can't guarantee you're gonna
find it your first job out but I always
told Colin students that come on I said
take the job that you would take if you
were independently wealthy
you know that's you're gonna do well at
it if you think you're going to be a lot
happier if you've got to X instead of X
you're probably making a mistake I mean
it guys in the auto you ought to find
something you like
that's that works with that and it and
you'll get in trouble if if you think
that making 10 X or 20 X is the answer
to everything in life because then you
will do things like borrow money when
you should endure or maybe cut corners
on things that your boy wants you to cut
corners on ER it just doesn't make any
sense you won't like it when you look
back on it happen my advice would be the
same for any kind of entrepreneur and
that is make sure that you are focused
on something you're passionate about so
if you look at the early internet
companies they were started and focused
on doing something that they thought was
very interesting long before the
internet was fashionable in anyway you
know I I you know we are currently an
underdog once again we've been in
business for six years and there was
exactly one year where we were not the
underdog and that was 1999 I like that
the underdog years because it makes you
know I liked it when all the people we
hired their parents told them they were
crazy
like that was the that was kind of the
good era fortunately it's back in 1999
all the parents were like you know given
their brothers and sisters high fives
you know my son is working at Amazon
calm so that's a very you can't follow
the fashion when you're trying to do a
startup company or I think really
anything in life but you have to as an
entrepreneur if you're gonna if you're
gonna build a company pick something you
think is interesting that has the
intersection of genuinely creating real
customer value and then just stay right
there and let the wave catch you well
now that we can see how short life
really can be what are you gonna do with
the rest of your life that's a trigger
that's the biggest trigger that I have
ever experienced what are you gonna do
the rest of your life and what I had to
do I had to start taking some of my own
advice I have been telling people I had
written about it for a very long time
that if you're doing something that
you're not totally committed to if
you're doing something that you're not
totally passionate about you're
compromising yourself every day I went
through the life and the military sports
and I always used the gym for some means
it was never about that it's modeling
I said passionate for lucky now every
time I hit struggles or I'll stressed
out I was going to the gym to find
solidity there and the work through any
kind of stresses so naps I got in shape
but it wasn't for a fitness model in
those for military and sports and then
later on down the road an agency agency
saw me it's an age to take some pictures
or no I'll try it and that's how this
was born but it wasn't the starting I
didn't start out set off with us it just
ended up coming through passion the
passion I've always had for business and
being an entrepreneur the trend that
transfers into the Mavs I've always been
passionate some people thought you know
it's a it's more OCD than anything else
which i think is a great trait for an
entrepreneur when I you know I mentioned
the stamp business I would stay up til
3:00 4:00 in the morning even though I
had to get up and go to school and read
Lin stamp news and Scots stamp journals
and have them all memorized and and use
that to give myself an edge even when I
was in college
I'd be in live in the library reading
business books and just looking for
business biographies and just reading
all I could about business when I had
Micro solutions and you know I started
with no money
you know I pull all-nighters in in front
of borrowed computers teaching myself
software and and how to program if you
really don't know you know what it means
to be an entrepreneur you know maybe art
one you know so I think there's a bit of
kind of self initiative and self starter
you know that that is incredibly
important part of entrepreneurship me no
one can sort of tell you how to do it
you have to sort of have an instinctual
you know feeling or an idea about about
something and you've got to be
passionate about them and I think people
that look for great ideas to make money
you know are nearly as successful as
those who say okay what do I really love
to do what am I excited about what I
know something about you know what's
kind of interesting and compelling we
decided this is the best weight upon
this was one thing and that was a
passion that I saw in your eyes for the
output and I knew that you would stick
with it because I knew that passion with
genja when you go out of venture capital
into whatever you're looking for people
who have a passion for money but you had
a passion for space life and I think
that's the difference
collection ran ran ran first what I say
well you want to excel at something what
must you have did I just hear somebody
say passion in the audience you know
what passion is passion is an emotion
it's an emotion without an action
passion will get you nowhere inner drive
will get you nowhere unless you act on
it you have to act on your passion you
have to act on your inner drive don't
let those feelings stay inside of you
you got to know what to do with them you
got to know how to make them work in
order to get what you want don't keep it
inside this is my little nice palace but
a specialized nice was and it's the kind
of thing that I pick myself up after
cycling to indicate a beautiful piece of
tuna she's gonna brush that first little
bit of mustard stops it from dry now
now sesame seeds just beautifully roll
that down I always think about food
everywhere I go so when I'm training you
know I'm never very far away from food
ID that extraordinary at the start of
Kona two years ago where I was paddling
at sort of hot past 5:00 in the morning
waiting for that amazing Canada to go
off to get rid of the nerves I just
started thinking about recipes and
dishes and how do I get through this 3.8
K swim the garnish
very very simple I've got potatoes I'll
start with a little teaspoon of olive
oil
at least ten is nice and crispy cut them
in half put that side down so in my bowl
there's some really nice Sherlock rings
olive Nicoise black olives some green
beans and then in there I'm just gonna
open up some of these little anchovies a
little touch of a New York this is
classic vinaigrette made with lots of
lemon juice and then just mix that up
nicely with some fresh
your tomatoes are sweet vinegar fresh
lemon juice in that lifts everything
worked 1415 hours a day to perfect an
absolute stunning dish it disappears in
two and a half minutes and that's what I
said
it loses you you you get on that journey
and nothing else matters except what you
put on the plate because you start off
with his raw ingredient and you go
through that journey 60 minutes later
you've got this this bit of magic also
it's an incredible passion it is a huge
canvas just take your cellophane order
use the little hearts just open them up
gently without sort of ripping them get
down to the heart and cut the parts into
four changes nice and crispy and then
from there as they start to cool down
put the vinaigrette over there and hit
them with food was my calling I think
because that was the way I could sort of
disappear disappear travel learn and get
really excited about something and my
first dream was to go to France to
understand why were they the sort of
foundation of cooking why do they start
it how do they start it and I disappear
I became French and within 18 months I
was fluent in the language I was holding
my own in a foreign kitchen and I I was
seriously cook my ass off now for the
dressing very very simple touch of the
vinaigrette and then some fresh lemon
juice
that gives a nice lightness vibrancy to
the dish as well just lightly dress them
my first set of knives was bought by a
charity and my parents can afford to
send me to cooking school and this knife
wallet was a swim mowers with bright
yellow handles and trust me I couldn't
cut butter but they looked the path my
mum had a tear in her eye because she
was upset she couldn't afford it my
first set of white and my first set of
knives I've still got them
finally the tuna the pan nice and hot
put a teaspoon of oil in there tuna into
the pan 90 seconds each side out
initially squeeze some fresh lemon juice
on there when you slice it let the knife
do the work fingers on top and just
slice through nice and carefully on
three nice slices food your journey and
there's something quite amazing about
the way you cook of giving pleasure my
dream when I started out as a chef was
to discover every ingredient and never
be intimidated and not know what to do
with it to that level of perfection I
think I'm about 97% of the way there
there must be about three or four
percent of ingredients that I still
haven't discovered yet and that's the
exciting thing about food that is what I
call my specialized Tuna Nicoise and
delicious thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know which of the clips had the greatest
impact on you leave it in the comments
below and I'm gonna join the discussion
thank you for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon